what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel is going in a direction that
I think a lot of fans are really going
to enjoy and that is kind of a darker
path which we need for the darker side
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe which
is about to become a much more prominent
side of the MCU that we see and we've
already started to see it a little bit
we got werewolf by night which was
definitely darker and I myself don't
typically like scary or horror-esque
genre types of movies or shows but I
actually quite enjoyed that special and
I am really looking forward to the
darker side of the MCU that's coming
with blade that's coming with the dark
magic that Agatha coven of chaos is
going to bring and more monsters and
horror-esque type of films and projects
and for a lot of people who have been
wanting more mature content from Marvel
Studios and just superhero content in
general well Marvel and Disney is going
to be giving that in a new report we
have learned that Marvel Studios is
essentially going to be diving deep into
the rated R side of some of these
characters that are known to be rated R
characters in the comics like Moon
Knight I think we all know some pretty
famous Moon Knight cussing quotes and
that is a part of who the character is
well at least one of them with Moon
Knight since he's got several
personalities but this is great because
it's going to allow Marvel to dive fully
into the characters who they truly are
like Deadpool you can't really have a
PG-13 Deadpool I mean you can but it's
not exactly the same is it Deadpool
needs to be raunchy and kind of over the
top plus we're not just talking about
swearing here we're talking about
violence if you're gonna have a Deadpool
vs Wolverine film there's definitely
going to be a lot of gory violence we've
already seen Logan we've seen the other
two Deadpool films we basically know how
the films should be not watered down and
this is true for all of the other
projects that could be rated either TV
mature or rated R now we haven't really
heard much about the Daredevil series
however one thing that people have been
talking about is how the Netflix
Daredevil series was rated TV mature and
that series is loved by many many fans
and people are scared that the mouse is
gonna kind of try to tame this and water
it down a little bit and it's not going
to be the same caliber as the Netflix
daredevil show was when it is the same
characters and that's the issue right
there since it's all the same characters
for the most part it's all the same lead
characters it has to be at the same
caliber it has to kind of be the same if
not even better and if you take away all
the gruesome fight scenes all those
graphic details that we saw in the
Netflix series it's just not going to be
the same now here's where it actually
gets pretty interesting we already knew
that some of the movies were gonna be
rated R however according to this recent
report from The Insider can we get some
toast Marvel's shows are also going to
be allowed to be TV mature the exact
report is Disney is allowing Marvel to
develop TV mature material on Disney
plus so that's pretty big because make
this distinction in your head for what
they wanted to do before if it was TV
mature if they had anything like that
they would go to Hulu they would put it
on Hulu right they don't want it on
Disney they don't want an Associated
really with that kid family friendly
name so they would put it on Hulu and we
thought it would kind of be the same for
Marvel however according to this new
report we are going to be getting TV
mature shows and it's not like TV mature
is that bad it's 17 and up but it is
going to allow these shows to kind of
reach their full potential if necessary
obviously they're not going to go out
and seek a TV mature rating but if the
character and the scenes and the
sequences call for it they can do it I'm
not expecting a rated R Spider-Man movie
or a rated TV mature Spider-Man show
they don't need to do that that's not in
the character although we have seen some
pretty brutal fight scenes from
Spider-Man but a lot of things are going
to happen in the MCU soon that could
actually require a different rating and
this does allow Marvel Studios to kind
of go all out with it for example
Mephisto is about to enter the MCU
according to a report from variety and
Mephisto is pretty much the Devil he's a
demon that rolls over the hell Dimension
and according to some insiders he's
going to be appearing in multiple
projects throughout the MCU so you can
probably imagine some scenarios where
some scenes with Mephisto would probably
be a bit much for a PG-13 rating after
all Mephisto is one of the foes of
doctor strange and we already saw
Multiverse of Madness and that was PG-13
but imagine if that was rated R I'm not
saying that it needed to be but perhaps
they went further with that with the
demons and with the hell realm well they
could take it further now and it's been
said that mephista will show up in some
Disney Plus shows as well Agatha coven
of chaos is one that he's rumored to
show up in and right now we don't know
what that's going to be rated we do know
it's going to talk about the dark hold
and dark magic is going to be a pretty
big aspect of that show so it could be
TV mature although it is coming off of
One Division so maybe not but the point
is Marvel Studios can essentially now do
what they want they're not restricted
they have the freedom to make shows what
they want them to be without being held
down by the mouse and this kind of
completes the full picture here because
they were already going to do this in
the MCU with movies and now they can do
it for their shows and there has been a
recent report that states that the
Punisher is also going to be getting his
own Disney Plus show and he is also
going to be appearing in the Daredevil
series as well he's going to make his
debut or red debut or whatever you want
to call it his reincarnation into the
MCU in the Daredevil Series so we
already know the TV mature rating is
appropriate for Daredevil because it was
before and the same with the Punisher
The Punisher Netflix series was amazing
and now that Disney is allowing Marvel
to make TV mature content it doesn't
mess with the Integrity of what made the
show so dang good in the first place
because let's be honest a lot of us were
worried that they were gonna tone it
down for Disney plus and that even
though we still have the same actors
playing the same iconic characters John
brenthal Charlie Cox Vincent D'Onofrio
if they limit their characters and
stifle them it's not gonna be the same
but now they are now we really kind of
don't have to worry it's all up to Kevin
feige now what happens now it is
important to note that I don't think
they're gonna go too overboard with the
swearing with the exception of course of
Deadpool 3. I'm sure every now and then
there's gonna be movies like that but I
think most of why Marvel Studios wants
TV mature content and rated R content
like for the upcoming blade movie is so
that they can actually have the violence
that they need to have blade Cuts people
in half Deadpool stabs people he cuts
them in half as well shoots him in the
head Wolverine jams his claws through
people's faces that's what it's really
about at its core being true to the
characters and what they do not just to
throw a million f-bombs out there
remember everything that Kevin feige
does is very carefully planned and he's
not just going to start to make
everything rated R or TV mature just for
the heck of it it's all part of the
master plan of the MCU to make those
darker movies the way that they're
supposed to be in the darker more brutal
shows how they're supposed to be as well
and with movies like blade Deadpool the
midnight Suns and shows like Daredevil
and The Punisher and characters like
Mephisto coming into the MCU all this
does is allow Marvel Studios and Kevin
feige to get these characters right
don't expect a Miss Marvel season 2
that's going to be rated TV mature
that's not how this works they're simply
getting the freedom to do the characters
the right way and I for one am excited
really excited about this Marvel Studios
has the freedom to do what they want and
that is always a great thing so let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget about
our giveaway we are starting a new
monthly giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to the channel and
leave a comment down below for your
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick a winner at the end of every month
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf